throughout the years you have seen me
cope with many weird items some of you
may know that in payable thing is there
are a long people robbers that are
usually used with the defensive playing
style when chopping the pimples
generates a great amount of unrest spin
on topspin shots but how difficult would
it be to learn to play with a long
pimple rubber and switch your playing
style from offensive to defensive would
it turn out to be a success or a
complete fail okay so now I have a brand
new table tennis racket I have the long
pimple on the red side and this is gonna
be extremely interesting to try this out
and see if I can do any jobs with this
so here begins the one-year chopping
challenge in this video I'll share my
thoughts on how changing my playing
style has felt so far one of the most
difficult things in the beginning was
the basic push and there you see the
that's the difficult part trying to push
with the long pimple if it's a backspin
it doesn't react the same way as a
normal rubber so you have to hit higher
to make it on table pushing with the
long peep requires a different technique
than pushing with an inverted rubber so
in the beginning pretty much all my long
peoplicious went Internet that just
proves how important it is to get like
the basic push first as if I can get
that on table and then the points are
very short try pushing a few different
as you can see in this clip pushing the
long bit feels very different to pushing
with the normal rubber whoo yeah it's
different this is the real real short
you need to practice yeah the most
underrated and the most boring but
probably the most important yeah exactly
I also realized that pushing was the
long people requires a longer stroke
because the ball isn't greedy impulses
is dust or normal rubber
during the first weeks everything felt
really difficult it was just very
difficult to find any consistency with
the chopping and sometimes having the
pimple rubber completely messed me up
hey what am i doing that was a blow
they're used to blocking it yeah and as
you can see here have included the
racket was another thing that I wasn't
used to but at the same time I had never
before it was quite playing with long
pips it was also very interesting and a
lot of fun to try it out when I
eventually started to get a bit of
feeling for the chopping the next
problem was that the chops were often
too high so high so it became very easy
for it just hit hard and I win the point
too high so the thing I have to learn is
to try to keep it chops lower above the
nets and also placed and better to make
it more difficult for the opponent
another thing that is important to
remember is that being a chopper means
that you have to be patient this is
something that is really difficult to
keep in mind since I've been playing
with an offensive playing style
basically my whole life before these two
months as an offensive player you want
to be in control of the game and making
shots yourself but as a chopper you are
doing pretty much the opposite just
trying to return the ball on table and
waiting for the opponent to make errors
[Music]
I also feel like I don't yet have the
consistency we get so many chops on the
table in a row so I often think that
it's more likely for me to get a point
by trying to counter-attack the topspin
rather than chop it but if I want to
improve this style I have to start
finding the confidence in my chops
[Music]
big chopper the movement is also very
important here is maybe the most
challenging part that being able to move
fast from here to here to be able to get
the long shot the fast one so a lot of
good footwork is required which I don't
have yet so I've been practicing my
chops with regular exercises for a while
now I try to focus on the technique and
the basics let's see if I can apply
anything of it in a real match it's
gonna be interesting to see the
difference with this set compared to
like after one year yeah it's probably
gonna be horrible
here you can clearly see the problem
with the pushing
as you can see in this one again match
everything it becomes much more
difficult when you don't know where the
goal is coming you don't really know
what to deal with a pimple where to move
and when to go find back what just much
more difficult than in regular exercises
and also it shows why you should do the
regular exercises in training
Oh
[Music]
so in short he can say that it's been a
quite challenging journey this far and
I've already several times especially
after playing some matches wanting to
change back to your invert Robert it's
sometimes hard to remember that it takes
a lot of time and practice to learn
enough lifestyle and reach even the same
level that you've had with the previous
play missed out it's long process and
requires much more training Oh doc sorry
don't return it it's my fault yeah but I
also have to say that it's been really
excited to try a new aspect of the
sporting if you understand chakras
better I think it's a very cool and fun
playing starwing it's better right so
I'll keep on fighting and fighting